in this segment we go through a quick
review of a few properties of the
Bernoulli process that we already know
we start by thinking about the number of
successes or arrivals in the first n
time slots this is the following
quantity at each time we add a 0 or a 1
depending on whether we've had a success
or not and by adding those numbers we
get the total number of successes now we
already know that the number of
successes in n trials obeys a binomial
distribution so the probability of
having K successes is given by the
binomial probabilities and this is a
formula that holds for k equal to 0 up
to n which are the possible numbers for
the random variable s for this random
variable we know the expected value it's
n times P and we also know it's variance
which is n times P times 1 minus P
another random variable of interest is
the time until the first success or
arrival so this is defined to be the
smallest I for which the random variable
X I is equal to 1 we have done this
calculation in the past the probability
that the first success appears at time k
is the same as the probability that the
first K minus 1 trials resulted in zeros
and then the case trial resulted in a 1
and so the probability of this is 1
minus P the probability of 0 and we have
K minus 1 of them times P the
probability that the next trial gives us
a success and this formula is valid for
K being 1 2 and so on which is the range
of possible values of this random
variable T 1 this is the familiar
geometric distribution that we have
dealt with in several locations and
particularly we know the expected value
and the variance of a geometric random
variable